- [Voiceover] This is
what it would be like if
Disney princesses wore realistic makeup.
Aurora would have some
seriously clumpy mascara
and raccoon eyes after sleeping that long.
Note the dried drool as well.
Had Mulan really tried
to wipe her makeup off
in two swipes with her sleeve, it wouldn't
have been that simple.
Even Ariel's waterproof mascara would
have been no match for
a lifetime under water.
And her hair wouldn't
have been camera ready.
Belle's magenta lip gloss
would have smeared everywhere
after making out with the Beast.
He would have ended up wearing it too.
Jasmine's liquid eyeliner, after a windy,
tear-inducing magic carpet ride,
may have moved a bit.
And again, her hair wouldn't have been
camera-ready.
And Princess Tiana's makeup definitely
wouldn't have been this perfect after...
oh, wait, it's her wedding day.
Yes, yes, it would have.
Bridal makeup artist magic.
(smooth electronic music)
(whoosh, creak)